I'm going to show you how they
manipulate you and why they don't like
shows like ours the Indian Express
reports selectively zoomed in video by
Republican Twitter account shows Biden
being lost on stage after speech for
what reason is the headline of this News
Guard certified Outlet saying
selectively zoomed in video by
Republican Twitter account why don't
they just say video shows Biden being
lost on stage after a speech they can't
do it I mean if they have they have to
prime it right it's not just in a well
it's not just the reporters people
understand like it it's the editors it's
it's the people who who write the
headlines you know you look well we used
to be straight news stories and
everything is now an editorial look at
this that News Guard is like they
actually put the logo in the store hey
wow look at that well just uh real quick
I'm gonna pull up this story from Tim
cast so you can all see that we here at
timcast IRL we're an opinion show but
our home base website timcast.com is
also certified by newsguard okay there
all right Indian Express
selectively zoomed in they've poisoned
the well because the reality is Joe
Biden got lost on stage and we will say
it and now they're saying oh he's saying
it again how do we get him to stop it's
simple guys just call me and offer me
the hundred million dollars already
I'm kidding they can't stop us they
can't
um we don't break the rules we try very
much to make a family-friendly show
debunking the lies and exposing this
manipulation the most important thing
here and the one thing they really don't
like is that we are outright exposing
how they're poisoning the well to make
you see this and say republican
Republican equals fake news no the
reality is there's a video outright look
at here you go let me play the video for
you and you tell me what you think I'm
not going to tell you what to think you
here's the video there you go
[Applause]
where's he gone what's he doing oh other
way no no
down oh
there we go uh Mr President thank you
I love that part yeah
still stuck thank you what's he doing
still stuck for all the millions what's
he doing whose lives will be saved
you're zoomed too far into him you gotta
zoom out what is this he's not lost
because like the characters know what to
do
yes he's lost now look he's not lost in
the sense of like where am I what
building is this he's lost in the sense
of he is confused and doesn't know
what's going on or what to do so when
you come out you're like man he looks
lost it could mean like lost in the
jungle or it could mean he doesn't know
what he's supposed to be doing right now
right and so they say it's manipulation
but look at his hands look when he walks
away from the podium what's he doing
with his Mr burn hands he he looks like
Ricky Bobby and Talladega Nights he's
doing that interview I don't know what
to do with my hands I don't know what to
do with my hands yeah right but he's
like what is this well I think what's
happening in that video and I don't know
for sure but it seems to me that Joe
Biden is sort of looking off camera to
some Handler in the back of the room
like what am I supposed to do next you
know because they probably primed him
for this like oh you're gonna go up
there you can give a speech and then
you're supposed to sit down or whatever
and Joe Biden just forgot I mean that's
probably what happened he probably just
doesn't know exactly and it's not the
first time we've seen this we've seen
this like over and over and over and get
again but what like the media wants to
do is like
like what are you gonna believe you're
gonna believe Tim are you gonna be in
your in Your Lying Eyes you're gonna
believe us look at G Prime 85 in the
responses this is a man I would follow
into the trenches
so I'll tell you I'll tell you why
they're mad I'll tell you why they're
pissed because uh I had someone comment
on my Facebook and it was a moment of
lucidity a moment of honesty and Clarity
and I was I was impressed it was a
leftist and there were people saying
things like you're a grifter
and this one person said the reason we
hate you so much is because you're
shattering consensus reality yes and I
went
yeah okay I I agree with that that is an
incredible compliment yeah yeah
um but in in their mind they're like
everyone must agree no matter what and
so uh I love the idea so now I'm working
on a song called consensus reality and
or maybe a concept album or something
but I'm like
at least they're honest but that
actually explains what's going on we see
a video of Joe Biden with his hands
confused and he's like daughtering about
confused we see videos of him reaching
out his hand to shake someone's hand but
there's nobody there and then he looks
confused we see him on stage in the
debates before he even got elected with
his teeth falling out his eyeball popped
too his eyeball popped in blood so
here's the issue
you know what I care about I like Julian
Assange I care about knowing the truth
and people having the ability to make
decisions for themselves based on the
best information they can get I don't
care what you do with your life just
don't hurt other people and that's
that's the right way to go about things
let me give you information the best of
my abilities that's accurate so you can
survive hey learn how to have chickens
learn how to have goats watch out there
might be a recession coming all that
good stuff and then you do you I do me
they don't like that because they think
if you shed her confidence in Joe Biden
during a time of war with Russia you're
putting our efforts at risk if you come
out and question the Ukrainian
propaganda and and and don't toe the
line 100 because I don't trust Vladimir
Putin either but I'm not going to sit
here and believe all the garbage lies
they spew about Ukraine just so I March
behind War they are pissed off about it
so you know what the real issue is it's
shattering consensus reality but it's
because the consensus reality gets
people to March and locks that behind
them as they go and blow up kids and
wage war for pipelines and oil and
Conquest
it's I think that's it ultimately it's
it's interesting what we like to call it
on our show is current thing enforcers
the current thing enforcers that really
and and this isn't just the media it's
it's your run-of-the-mill liberals on
the internet now too that you know they
put the right flag at that at the right
time on their Twitter bio you know
they're enforcing the sort of lockstep
thing Tim that you're describing here
and then they've sort of made it their
lives their lives work to sort of uh
attack people who challenge that I don't
know where that comes from why people
dedicate their lives to this but it's
fascinating and it's only come in the
last few years and then you know I mean
that DHS uh uh disinformation board that
Nina jankow was remember they were going
to create that administrative truth the
government was going to tell us you know
what the truth was they actually tried
to they actually tried to uh
institutionalize this current thing
enforcer her job was basically going to
be to be the Karen of the internet yeah
yeah so tomorrow I'm gonna see it
armored truck pull up two guys ensues
are going to walk out with a couple
briefcases and they're going to just pop
them open when there's going to be a
contract and they'll be like we agree
I'm gonna be like oh no
yeah that's the thing you know um
I can't there's something akin to uh you
guys know the the the economic hit man
what was it called Tales tells Luke do
you know this one the economic Hitman
um what was that it was the book was
called economic Hitman
um I forgot that his name confessions
so what he said was basically you know
first they'll go to a country and say
hey do X then the person says no Then
they come back and say okay if you do X
we'll give you y then the person says no
Then they say okay we're invading you to
remove you to get someone who will do it
so it's like we want oil or we want
bananas or who knows what there's
something similar
um in in the United States with with
everything it's how it works and it's
it's not a conspiracy it's just basic
power power structures the first thing
that happens is they'll be like hey
you're doing a really great job why
don't you come work for me you say no
then they come back to you and say why
don't you come and work with this
company for a large sum of money you say
no then all of a sudden you're banned
stripped kicked out whatever they shut
you down so I really do think what we're
seeing now is
after the Banning of Alex Jones it
caused a massive ripple effect and that
had negative consequences the rise of
parlor gab mines now truth social and
they're like whoa that was bad parlor
was really scary for him yeah because
parlor was was a meteoric rise so they
colluded to shut it down that was a that
was overt like we watched that happen
that's so crazy it's right in your face
they're smart now they've got to do it
silently and slowly the strategy now I
had a guy from a former Trump
Administration guy tell me this he said
the goal is
if conservative media is effective 60 of
the time that means over a long enough
period of time Democrats lose so what
they need to do is hobble the
conservatives only by 11 to put them at
49 so that Democrats hit 50 and overtime
Democrats win so they're avoiding now
the hardcore overt Banning they're doing
it very very slowly to create a
narrative like oh Crowder got a strike
because he did this then they're going
to wait then they're gonna every time
they give them a strike they're knocking
them off YouTube for two weeks and that
is effective a lot of people are saying
stuff like why don't you go to rumble
well rumble's great but I'll tell you
this Their audience is very very much
one one demographic YouTube has gen Z
that's why YouTube is very much like we
gotta shut this stuff down
that's the game they're playing slow
slow attrition yeah Confessions by
economic Hitman a great book by John
Perkins and in the book he detailed
exactly how the IMF the World Bank were
working with U.S Intel agencies to
extort coerce and manipulate developing
countries for the benefit of an
unaccountable ruling corporate banking
Elite so he talks about invested
interests of governments not working for
the benefit of the people but working
for the benefit of the people who put
them in charge and that of course are
the special interests and the big powers
that of course are there behind the
scenes and of course these same powers
are obviously doing the same thing
understanding that now on the internet
people have a lot of power people have a
lot of influence they want that power
they want all that influence and they're
going to do anything and everything just
to make sure that they have a monopoly
on it and then you see you see other
countries see that model and and put
into effect themselves like China with
Belton Road they're like huh it's kind
of like a Monster yeah it's kind of it's
kind of like the mafia Tim to your point
of like you know how are they changing
their strategy and in this it's it's not
just the outright bands it's more like
the mafia walking into your your
restaurant and saying wow nice place you
got here be shame if anything would have
happened to it yes you know I couldn't
help but notice just selling that uh
chicken I sell chicken too maybe you
should sell beef and you're like I don't
want to sell beef okay and then he pulls
out the Crowbar and says I'm gonna I'm
gonna say it again maybe you should sell
the beef and then you're like it's like
get in line and sell it which one what
we want you to sell or else yeah I do
think it's funny though and and you know
I don't know your guys's backgrounds
like where do you guys come from what's
your background
um I'm from Indianapolis originally
um love the Midwest not for what about
you born in Denver raised in the South
North Carolina but you guys you do you
come from Silver Spoon families and
trust funds and Ivy Leagues and all that
stuff nope no I mean my family's I'm
very well proud to be a state college
grad and have Ivy Leaguers work for me
oh no I I I went to IU go Hoosiers so I
I think that's like that kind of hits
the nail on the head with the hammer why
they don't like us for the most part so
over the summer we had a total of I
think like 24 Billboards yeah 24 I
shouldn't say Billboards but uh on on
three separate Billboards 24 ads in
Times Square for a bunch of our projects
we got a big old Michael malice Lou
gradkowski Ian Crossland me up on these
massive Billboards I had a big vinyl one
and it really triggered a lot of these
people to see us in their space like
right above the ABC building but I bring
this up because
I asked Luke like what do your parents
think did they ever think that you
running and chasing after a Rothschild
would result in him getting a billboard
in Times Square 95 feet tall and that's
kind of the point he's not supposed to
the Rothschilds I mean who else kiss
history uh Ben Bernanke these powerful
Elites are like this guy this this salt
of the earth dude challenging me and the
things I do is not someone who's
supposed to be standing next to me on
top of the mountain and at some point
for some reason they lost control and
here we are and now they're like uh oh
and that's the thing is is there is a
class that thrives on predictability
that it absolutely for them to maintain
what they have I mean you see right now
it's become crystal clear that there is
absolutely an academic Coastal
University class of individuals who
demand that the world exists in the way
that they want and and if you have any
sort of a Viewpoint which imposes that
you're a bigot you need to be silenced
you're danger you're a domestic
terrorist and and an extension of this
is whenever they they see something that
did not go how they planned it and
doesn't ensure that the boat is not
rocked I mean goes right back to Trump
getting elected it just outrages them
and and seeing the swing back like the
amount of of of of force that they
brought to bear against Trump is
unprecedented when a former president
can get kicked off of social media I
mean that's that's got to be stunning I
mean they decide they decided because
Hillary Clinton lost an election they
would break the internet or or try to I
mean that was the the temper tantrum
that they threw after 2016. are you all
familiar with uh debt internet Theory no
no no I I think it's it's probably
partially true to a certain degree it's
the idea that around 2016 the internet
slowly transformed into a completely
astroturfed platform where very few real
people actually exist and I think that's
probably true
I think there's probably verified
individuals then uh the reason I think
it's probably true is because whenever I
go to events I meet people regular
people and they're just like oh I'm
banned from Twitter so I can't follow
you and I'm like
really why would happen like oh I had
300 followers and they just banned me
and I'm like really I'm wondering if at
some point there was a real concern with
regular people being able to organize
online particularly look you look at the
Arab Spring then trumps Victor and they
went oh it can happen here yeah so I
think to a certain degree it's the NPC
in the internet they've created the NPC
no exactly yeah that's why when Elon
Musk was like I'm gonna buy Twitter all
of the right-wing voices and libertarian
moderate type saw huge gains yeah and
all the left and celebrities dropped
dramatically that was the fake reality
these these leftist personalities these
leftist politicians and celebrities had
fake followers because that was the
approved consensus reality and when they
thought Elon Musk was coming in they
panicked and then something got reversed
overnight yeah it's it's like when your
parents gonna come home you gotta clean
your room really really quickly
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there